[Music]
the main focus on this report which is
the first of its kind is about the
widespread and the gypsies what I want
to present is the root cause of the
exclusion and why the stigmatization of
the Roma the situation is really
indecent in almost all of the member
states like in Sweden for example which
is a very rich and developed country
eighty percent of the Roma are
unemployed we never recognized and the
gypsies its individual level and
institutional level its structure and it
is very old I mean since the Roma came
to Europe like 800 years ago Europe has
to recognize their failure member state
has to recognize the failures me myself
am not so Roma and I know that I was
born condemned because there are so many
prejudice and so much against me because
of my ethnicity now it is about time to
take full responsibility also for these
people nobody wants to be poor nobody
wants to live like kettles
nobody wants not to send their children
to school nobody wants to live without
electricity nobody wants to live without
water if we are going to be a proud
Union we cannot be that as long as we
have like 1012 million people living
totally excluded from everything
you